es muy probable que estés familiarizado
con la idea de hallar el área entre dos
curvas y si no es así te encargó que
revises este tema en la canaca de mí por
ejemplo podemos encontrar esta área en
amarillo
usando una integral definida lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es algo aún
más interesante vamos a encontrar el
volumen de algunas figuras donde la base
está definida de alguna manera como el
área entre dos curvas y en este vídeo
vamos a pensar en una figura que
dibujaremos en tres dimensiones así que
déjame dibujar esto de nuevo pero con un
poco de perspectiva hagamos este el eje
james
y este de cam mi eje x
por lo tanto esta será mi recta que
igual a 6
y esta sería la recta punteada
por lo tanto aquí tendríamos el punto x
igual a 2
ahora la gráfica de la función que igual
a 4 veces el logaritmo natural de 3 - x
se va a ver algo así y por lo tanto la
región sombreada será esta región pero
esta vez serán la base de una figura en
tres dimensiones donde cualquier sección
transversal si tomo una sección
transversal por aquí esta sección será
un cuadrado sea cual sea este largo eso
mismo tendrá de altura y por lo tanto la
sección transversal es un cuadrado
aquí por ejemplo esta sección
transversal también será un cuadrado sea
cual sea la diferencia entre estas dos
funciones tendrán eso mismo de altura y
por ejemplo hasta acá esta longitud que
es de 6 en este punto también tendrán lo
mismo de altura así de grande déjame
subir un poco la pantalla para que
quepan y tenga la proporción adecuada
algo así y observa es un cuadrado se ve
algo así entonces toda la figura se va a
ver
de esta forma muy bien déjame sombrear
un poco para que se aprecie mejor el
dibujo y con suerte ya tienes la idea en
la mente seguramente algunos de ustedes
se sienten emocionados y tal vez otros
se sientan un poco intimidados y digan
oye hemos trabajado tanto tiempo en dos
dimensiones que pasa ahora con tres
dimensiones rápidamente puedes apreciar
que tenemos el poder de la integración
para resolver este ejercicio
para eso tendremos que dividir la figura
en un montón de estos pequeños azulejos
cuadrados que tienen una pequeña
profundidad o anchura así que aquí
tenemos un pequeño azulejo
por acá tendremos otro muy bien también
tiene una pequeña profundidad y podría
seguir dibujando muchos de ellos en
varios lugares por eso estamos
dividiendo en estos azulejos que tienen
un ancho muy pequeño que podemos llamar
de equis y con esto ya sabemos encontrar
su volumen cuál sea el volumen de uno de
estos azulejos bueno tenemos que
multiplicar el ancho por el área de la
cara de esta sección transversal así que
cuál va a ser el área de esto que estoy
sombreando en color rosa
bueno esta área será la longitud de la
base elevada al cuadrado porque tenemos
un cuadrado recuerdas ahora bien cuál es
la longitud de la base
bueno será la diferencia entre estas dos
funciones serán 6 menos mi función
inferior que es 4 veces el logaritmo
natural de 3 menos x
esto nos dará la longitud de la base y
se ahora lo elevamos al cuadrado
obtendremos esta área total y si ahora
lo multiplicamos por de x que es el
ancho entonces tendremos el volumen de
este pequeño azulejo de esta pequeña
sección de aquí y creo que ya sabes a
dónde va todo esto porque ahora qué pasa
si sumas todos estos volúmenes desde x
igual a cero hasta x igual a 2 bueno
obtendrás el volumen de toda la figura y
este es el poder de la integral definida
por lo tanto podemos integrar desde x
igual a cero hasta x igualdad 2
y si dibujas en donde eso intersecta con
tu base podrás ver que este azulejos de
aquí ínter seca en este pequeño
rectángulo de aquí donde tenemos a de x
pero en lugar de multiplicar a de x por
la diferencia entre estas dos funciones
vamos a elevar al cuadrado la diferencia
de estas dos funciones porque estamos
visualizando una figura en tres
dimensiones observa estamos comparando
el área de la superficie de esta figura
de tres dimensiones en contraposición
con la altura de este pequeño rectángulo
y si ahora que es evaluar esta integral
obtendrás en efecto el volumen de esta
cosa que es un tipo de megáfono
ahora bien ésta no es una integral que
se pueda calcular a mano fácilmente pero
podemos usar una calculadora para
encontrarla
en esta calculadora podemos seleccionar
la opción de más y elegir la opción 9
para integrarles definidas y ahora
tenemos que poner la función que
escribimos vamos de 0 a 2
y abriré otro paréntesis y después lo
elevaría al cuadrado tengo seis menos
cuatro veces el logaritmo natural de 3 -
x déjame cerrar el paréntesis del
logaritmo natural y ahora voy a cerrar
el paréntesis de la expresión y lo voy a
elevar al cuadrado ok y por último tengo
que poner que estoy integrando todo esto
con respecto a x entonces esto va a ser
aproximadamente igual a am a 26.27
entonces aproximadamente 26.27 es el
resultado de esta integral y como estoy
hablando de volumen entonces si pensamos
en las unidades tendrían el cubo de las
unidades o unidades al cubo y qué creés
ya con esto hemos terminado es todo así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo